I'm Lauren I write a column for GQ
called ask a real live lady and I'm here
to answer all the questions you'd feel
too stupid to ask a woman you actually
know dear ask a real live lady I have a
lot of hair on my back my shoulders my
nostrils I've been told I should wax it
off it is okay to have body hair
you're a dude I mean I guess if you can
Rapunzel out a window using your Pitt
locks you should take a scissor to do it
every once in again but over manicuring
is a real turnoff
we like men even ones that leave those
little pupae body hairs all over the
sheets I'd almost always rather think
wow this dude has a [ __ ] ton of back
hair than oh this dude clearly went to a
salon and paid a mean Russian lady to
smear hot wax on him and rip it off
violently how many men mine when a guy
fails to plug his unibrow I just do it
for her honey sleep oh the guy who cares
that much about how he looks implies
that Ryan Seacrest lacks and dull person
vanity yes I realize I'm saying that as
I spread my cookie into my pores just
imagine those Hillbillies on duck
dynasty is sporting shiny clean bones
pubis --is or brazilian butt waxes now
never imagine that again
I hope this scares you into keeping your
own pit hair if you have a question for
ask a real live lady you can email me at
GQ advice at gmail.com